so the first thing I wanted to ask you
about was something I had read a good
deal about in the production notes the
opportunity to improv while making an
animated movie I'm always curious to
hear about how far you could push it
when there's so many departments and
artists involved so to kind of paint a
picture of that can you tell me a little
bit about the very first version of
Donkey Kong you were pitched and how
that evolved and wound up being what we
see in the finished film now uh
definitely
um yeah with animated movies honestly
often you're rarely been given like a
full script for some reason I don't know
why because there always is one they
just don't give it to the actors and
I've made them and they're like should
we give the actors the script and I'm
like yeah they're like we don't usually
do this I'm like just give it to them
um so that's where so you kind of are
like pitched it
um yeah I think the original description
was that yeah he was kind of
really like seeking his father's
attention and
um kind of a Showboat maybe those were
some of the words used and
um and yeah it seemed it seemed funny
and and
um but mostly yeah the world seemed
impressive and uh it seemed like they
were gonna
actually like make a version of this
that was you know exciting for fans as
opposed to the first uh version I saw as
an 11 year old that was uh not exciting
for fans and so yeah then you yeah then
you're alone in a room like this with a
microphone and and they animate after
that you've recorded and so they you you
record and you try tons of stuff it's
you alone in a room basically with uh
and so there's really very little
pressure on time and and whether or not
it's everything is good or working you
know because it's it's a relatively
inexpensive way to capture performance
as in comparison to some of the other
ways we capture performance in in this
job you know
um and so you can get a lot of material
and then they take it and they edit it
together into like a radio play
essentially and then they take that and
they and they animate it but
um but yeah I was alone completely on
this movie that's not oh always how it
is but this one yeah I I literally never
saw another actor so I was like like a
crazy person alone in a room
um just screaming at my just screaming
at myself I mean that works for you you
absolutely crush it in the role thank
you
um so I've also read the rumors that
Donkey Kong could get a spin-off movie
and I I do hope that really happens
because I walked out of this movie like
feeling wanting that but like in a
natural way and not in a way that this
movie is teeing that up and kind of
forcing that at me which I really
appreciated but let's say you get the
opportunity to do that is there any
particular corner of Donkey Kong's world
or personality that you would hope that
that movie would explore most
um I don't know I mean I uh there
there's a lot of opportunity there I
think the family unit of the Kongs seems
to be and if the Fast and Furious films
have taught us anything
that it's all about family so it did an
animated Fast and Furious movie and I
love it go-karts it kind of you know
there's a lot of crossover I'll end with
the most serious question you'll
probably hear all day but one of my
favorite parts of this movie is how
Luigi is there to support Mario's goals
and Ambitions even when others won't so
I want to know in your career who is
your Luigi in this crazy industry when
you have a really big dream or idea who
is always there to back you up on it
um well I'm lucky because I have a
partner uh his name's Evan Goldberg we
worked together since we were 12 since
since that first movie came out uh bad
and yeah and having a partner honestly
like is invaluable to me and and we do
that both to each other and and and when
one doesn't think an idea is great the
other often like helps the like helps
you know bring it bring it there you
know um and sometimes we both think an
idea is bad and we're right but but I
think just having someone there to
bounce off of and to uh kind of really
be there uh with you along the way to me
has been very valuable and I've seen a
lot of writers who don't have partners
and and how much harder it is honestly
and and and how much that like kind of
built-in support system is is helpful
you know should have guessed you would
have gone for Evan a an excellent Duo
that I love seeing in this business
uh they're gonna kick me out of here
huge congratulations and I genuinely do
want to see that spin-off now yeah
exactly thanks